bonsoir nous sommes le vendredi 20 mai
nouvelle édition de votre journal de fin
de semaine voici les principaux titres
hier soir lille b loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines accueillait la 9e
édition du trophée des entreprises 180
équipes s'étaient donné rendez-vous pour
s'affronter dans un raid d'environ une
heure mêlant course orientation et
entraide
irina brook actrice metteur en scène
franco britannique de théâtre et d'opéra
vient créer l'événement à saint quentin
en yvelines elle livre sa version rock
du classique peer gynt une version en
partie met en musique par iggy pop et
comme chaque vendredi le zapping de
l'information locale faut-il retenir de
cette semaine entre des policiers qui
s'inquiète des violences dont ils sont
victimes
une élue de la majorité à saint quentin
qui dénonce des comportements sexistes
de ses collègues mais aussi est aussi à
la grève des agents du château de
versailles et l'essor d'autolib dans les
yvelines pour débuter cette édition les
images du conseil municipal de plaisir
qui se tenait hier soir et cette
exclusion du groupe majoritaire de la
droite et du centre de plusieurs élus
trois élus démis de leurs fonctions
d'adjoints et deux délégués pour s'être
opposé à l'augmentation des impôts dans
la commune la maire évoque une nécessité
de cohérence dans son action deux autres
élus de la majorité ont choisi de ne pas
cautionner cette sanction est de les
rejoindre pour former un nouveau groupe
baptisé libre et indépendant nous y
reviendrons plus en détail dans notre
édition de lundi
la neuvième édition du trophée des
entreprises à présent qui vient de se
tenir à saint quentin en yvelines
une compétition qui permet aux salariés
de cette agglomération de s'inscrire par
équipes et d'échangés dans un autre
cadre que celui du travail mélanie poker
était à l'île des loisirs attrape août
avait lieu l'événement
les 190 qui s'échauffe une dernière fois
dans le départ pour sa neuvième édition
le trophée rassemble une soixantaine
d'entreprises de l'agglomération
ça fait trois ans qu'on refusait du
monde ont limité à 150 équipes
à force de refuser on a essayé de voir
comment nos remodifier les épreuves pour
augmenter la jauge trophée ce qu'on a
fait cette année on se rend compte que
ça permet effectivement de voir ses
collègues sous un autre jour ça resserre
les liens et puis on s'est rendu compte
également qu'ils aient une réelle
demande de la part des entreprises de
prendre en compte la question du sport
que ce soit sur les tours du midi sur
les temps juste après le travail et sur
des événements comme ça
course d'orientation épreuve de radom
relais vtt ou encore sprint
le trophée est avant tout un moment de
cohésion entre salariés ça nous permet
de nous connaître nous mieux nous
connaître d'apprendre aussi à vivre
ensemble à participer aux efforts de
l'entreprise d'une part mais ose
également des efforts qui sont plus
sportifs
et puis aussi affectif entre mai et août
et 3 on échange à ce qu'on va faire on a
regardé les cartes de l'année dernière
voilà on en parlait même demain la
débilité
ça apporte oui de la cohésion la
solidarité ça permet aussi rencontrer
des personnes dans l'entreprise qu'on
rencontre pas forcément tous les jours
et voilà créer l'esprit d'équipé
boncourt régulièrement quatre à cinq
fois par semaine on a fait beaucoup de
radeaux beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et du
vtt du vtt du vtt et la course
d'orientation bas dans le bureau pour
cette édition 2007 un trio masculin de
la ceppm basée à montigny le bretonneux
qui l'emportent pour la deuxième année
consécutive
économie il ya un peu moins d'un an la
plateforme d'intégration et de test de
l'ové est ce qu était inaugurée à
guyancourt là à pitre ce sont des
équipements uniques en europe au service
des laboratoires des étudiants de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
quelles sont les innovations qui
caractérise cette plateforme comment
pérenniser leur activité également
visite guidée avec fanny bourdillon ici
vous vous trouvez au coeur de
l'innovation dans ce pot vibrant
comprenait un laboratoire où des petits
satellites sont testés on vérifie qu'il
supporte bien les vibrations avant leur
envoi dans l'espace la plateforme
d'intégration et de test de l'ové excuse
située à guyancourt recoupent des
équipements scientifiques unique en
france des moyens que l'on a ici pour la
plupart sont assez innovant certains
n'existent pas forcément dans d'autres
centres
france ou même en europe la machine donc
derrière moi là
qui est une cuve à vide à la base qui
permet de recréer l'environnement de
l'espace
la fonctionnalité qui vous permet de
recréer l'atmosphère martienne est tout
à fait unique en france et peut-être
même en europe
autre innovation de la plateforme ce mur
d'image immersif il sert à faire de la
modélisation 3d
en ce moment les équipes simule le champ
magnétique de mercure inauguré en juin
la pite comme on l'appelle ici a coûté 6
millions d'euros l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
la région ile-de-france et le cnes ont
participé au financement
désormais il reste à pérenniser
l'activité sont des moyens qui demandent
des financements importants
ne serait ce qu'en termes de maintenance
pour maintenir ses moyens en conditions
opérationnelles
donc notre capacité à offrir du service
nous permet de compenser dans une
certaine partie ces financements que
l'on
on doit avoir la plateforme
d'intégration et de test est ouvert aux
chercheurs et aux étudiants mais pas
seulement
il souhaite aussi se rapprocher du monde
industriel local
la start-up saint-quentinoise sky one
portal utilisent déjà le mur d'image
immersif manuel valls a décidé mardi 10
mai d'engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement sur le vote du projet de
loi travail conformément à l'article 49
3 de la constitution conséquence le
projet est considéré comme adopté et
dans la rue une colère qui continue à
s'exprimer stéphane minson bonsoir
monsieur le doyen honoraire de la
faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin professeur de
droit public on va peut-être déjà
préciser ce qu'est le 49 3 et donc
quelques à son usage est possible alors
il s'agit bien de l'article 49 alinéa 3
n'est pas tiré 3 cet article de la
constitution le grand public le connaît
parce qu'il est fréquemment utilisée
depuis 1958 on l'a lu dans la presse ces
derniers jours 85 fois et il sert en
gros pour expliquer les choses le plus
simplement possible à permettre au
gouvernement d'engager devant
l'assemblée nationale sa responsabilité
politique
à l'occasion de la présentation devant
cette assemblée d'un projet de loi c'est
à dire que en clair lorsque le
gouvernement le décide
eh bien il peut contraindre le parlement
à discuter non pas de l'adoption du
texte proposé mais à discuter de
l'opportunité ou non de renverser
politiquement le gouvernement donc le
débat se déporte d'une question
l'adoption d'un texte vers une autre
doit-on ou non laisser en place
le gouvernement doit proposer une motion
de censure on l'a vu c'était un peu le
feuilleton après le dépôt de 149,3
puisqu'elle finalement la motion de
censure n'a pas elle n'a pas été retenue
parce que c'est déjà arrivé justement
par le passé qu'un gouvernement
d'engager sa responsabilité soit
désavoué alors c'est arrivé une choix en
octobre 1962 le gouvernement de georges
pompidou et a été mis en minorité par
l'assemblée nationale mais pas sur le
fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3
plutôt sur le fondement d'une motion de
censure spontanée c'était l'époque à
laquelle le général de gaulle avait donc
instaurer l'élection du président de la
république au suffrage universel direct
donc première élection 65 et les
parlementaires les députés en
l'occurrence était farouchement opposé à
ce nouveau mécanisme et ont donc
renverser le gouvernement lorsqu'il
s'est passé et ce qui se passe en
principe même en théorie lorsque le
gouvernement est renversé et bien le
président de la république qui en a le
pouvoir
prononce la dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale ce qui renvoie la question au
fond en dernier lieu devant les
électeurs 49,3 utilisées à plus de 80
reprises vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
entre 88 et 91 michel rocard l'a utilisé
28 fois manuel valls à ces quatre fois
pour l'instant ça traduit quoi le
recours au camp 9,3 c'est un aveu
d'échec finalement pour un gouvernement
non c'est parce que c'est vécu comme
antidémocratiques même si ça reste
inscrit dans la constitution ce n'est
surtout pas antidémocratique le jeu
normal des institutions le jeu politique
consiste pour l'opposition du moment a
annoncé à grand renfort de slogans etc
mais cette disposition a là rien d'anti
démocratique au moins pour deux raisons
la première est une raison à peu près
légitimiste si vous voulez c'est que
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la constitution
eh bien il a été adopté à l'instar des
autres dispositions constitutionnelles
par le peuple
il ya eu un référendum de 1958 qui a
permis aux électeurs d'accepter
d'adopter le texte considère qu'ils sont
tout sauf une anomalie démocratique
comme mozart grillons mâles ou être
tentés de croire
et puis une seconde raison c'est que au
fond cette disposition 49 alinéa 3 l
comment dirais-je elle place une
question décisive entre les mains des
députés cette question décisive c'est le
fait de savoir s'il faut ou non laisser
en place le gouvernement et cette
question là elle est absolument
démocratique
donc le fait que le les gouvernements
parce que c'est pas une un système
prendre à la france ça s'appelle le
parlementarisme rationnalisé le fait que
les gouvernements disposent de ce genre
d'outil fait partie des techniques de
gouvernement et vous l'avez dit michel
rocard sans l'article 49 alinéa 3
n'aurait pas pu gouverner puisqu'il ne
disposait que d'une majorité relative
donc ça n'est pas une anomalie
ça fait partie du jeu des institutions
est ce qu'on peut imaginer un
gouvernement revenir sur ces
dispositions cette loi adoptée
finalement en force
lorsqu'on voit les contestations qui se
poursuivent ou françois hollande dire je
ne lâcherai rien il va aller jusqu'au
bout vous savez qu on a vu mieux
c'est à dire qu'on a vu gouvernement
villepin adopté un texte promulgué par
le président de la république c'est à
dire si neil présent plus que n'a pas le
choix il doit promulguer la loi et le
présent de république jacques chirac à
l'époque qui s'était empressé de dire on
va on va pas appliquer le texte
donc voyez que politiquement tout est
possible même si aujourd'hui le texte
est considéré comme adopté
c'est pas pour ça qui entrera en vigueur
alors il est pas encore considéré comme
un docteur il est en discussion au sénat
et il reviendra en avant l'assemblée
nationale et c'est à ce moment là qu'ils
seraient adoptés ou pas et on pourrait
encore imaginer que derrière il ne soit
pas appliquée parce qu'il faudra
toujours un décret d'application
on l'a déjà vu ça s'est déjà vu donc les
manifestants au final ont raison de
continuer le bras de fer s'est sellers
l'histoire l'a prouvé ou pas en tout cas
libre historiquement ça s'est déjà
produit
on va s'écarter peut-être un petit peu
cette question de droit justement plus
voir la politique est juste avoir votre
regard là-dessus puisqu'on vous fait
souvent intervenir sur des questions
politiques aussi sur cette antenne
le divorce est consommé au sein de la
gauche enfin je teins divorce qui
couvrent de longue date vous avez ont
fait les 80 ans du front populaire en
1936 léon blum léon blum avait avait
théorisé léon blum était un assez grand
penseur delà de la question politique et
il était conseiller d'état un grand
juriste aussi et il avait déjà écrit
beaucoup sur ces de gauche est en
substance il disait au fond il ya une
gauche une gauche idéal y ait une gauche
de gouvernement
il ya une gauche de campagne électorale
et une gauche qui lorsqu'elle arrive aux
affaires se trouvent confrontés à la
réalité à la dure réalité des choses et
qui doit composer avec cette réalité
donc ce divorce au fond il
je sais pas jusqu'où il ira ce qu'il ira
vraiment vers une rupture totale mais en
tout état de cause c'est une espèce de
situations qui couve si vous voulez qui
est propre à la gauche et pas seulement
française enfin plutôt française depuis
déjà des années
et puis une toute dernière question
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lu votre
université a changé de président aussi
et didier guillemot succède à jean luc
vestiaire on en a parlé sur cette
antenne quel est votre sentiment à mon
sentiment c'est que la démocratie la
poésie ya pas de 49 alinéa 3 le
président est l'élu de la communauté
universitaire à une nouvelle équipe se
met en place et puis on va voir enfin en
tout cas bonne chance je nous souhaite
bonne chance
merci stéphane danse on vous retrouve ce
week end aussi sur l'antenne de
téléphiles aux côtés des chroniqueurs du
paf avec patrice carmouze pour revenir
sur l'ensemble de l'actualité
merci à vous avec les cultures à présent
et c'est un événement irina brook met en
scène une nouvelle version de peer gynt
c'est au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines depuis hier et
jusqu'à samedi soir une version rock
avec plusieurs compositions signées iggy
pop camille lambert
guitare électrique et attitudes
provocantes
le peer gynt d'irina brook est une
rock-star ambitieux et insolent une
version décalée du drame politique
norvégien de 1876 imaginé par la metteur
en scène a dit me rends j'avais lu la
pièce j'avais été absolument
j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire cce
extraordinaire elles sont de conte de
fées mythique et existentielle aventures
d'une vie extraordinaire et donc à
l'époque je me suis dit mme bien que je
sois pas du tout metteur en scène ce
serait génial de famille production de
cette pièce comme un opéra rock avec
iggy pop et david bowie un rêve
d'adolescente devenu presque réalité en
iggy pop a composé deux morceaux du
spectacle chanteurs danseurs comédiens
et musiciens se côtoient pendant les
deux heures de show avec un casting
international et ses listes en day in
var sigurdsson acteur de cinéma et de
théâtre qui incarne le personnage
torturé de pizzi annemans challenge de
jouer peer gynt comme une rock star
il est sujet de pierre clint est
toujours le même il à propos de lego et
comment les boucles devenir destructeur
j'ai la chance de jouer seul mais qui
est le symbole de la pureté mais de
jouer aussi à la princesse des trolls
qui est justement l'opposé qui devient
ensuite une vieille sorcière hargneuse
et horrible et c'est un peu le voyage de
perkins et le voyage de cet homme qui
cherche qui il est qu'est ce que c'est
le soin qu'est ce que c'est d'être un
être humain qui suis-je c'est la
question posée tout au long de la
comédie irina brook définissons peer
gynt comme une pièce épique musical tout
en conservant la profondeur métaphysique
l'oeuvre originale un résultat moderne
et électriques joué au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines jusqu'au
samedi 21
là
voilà pour cet événement culturel et
c'est à saint quentin en yvelines et
culture toujours est le dernier volet de
notre série consacrée aux yvelinois
présent au festival de cannes
elle n'oublie pas d'ailleurs que
l'intégralité de cette série est à
retrouver sur notre site internet grâce
au replay rencontre donc aujourd'hui
avec ludovic de gaillande c'est un élève
de l'école 3 i/s à trappes qui a réalisé
un court métrage inscrits au short film
corner guèye pineau programmateur du
cinéma du grenier à sel à trappes qui
lui nous parlera des enjeux du festival
pour les exploitants et puis enfin une
jeune comédienne de sartrouville armelle
habibou qui elle nous parlera de sa
collaboration avec le réalisateur
mansonnien sylvain chomet le sujet à
suivre est signée josée fille joséphine
aracil léger alexis garneau et grégory
canale
bienvenue sur la croisette cannes c'est
la terre des cinéphiles c'est aussi une
belle vitrine médiatique ludovic de
gaillande compte bien en profiter pour
se faire connaître
ce natif de nouvelle calédonie a eu un
parcours plutôt atypique et après un
master de sciences politiques il s'est
très vite tourné vers le cinéma
c'est comme ça que ludovic s'est
retrouvé au troisième l'institut
international de l'image et du son de
trappes ryan au short film corner
ludovic est venu présenter son nouveau
corps métrage var dogger film librement
inspiré d'une légende nordique frommer
prend moins d'une semaine
ça ne fait pas peur ce malade qui se
balade dans les rues est-ce que c'est
toi qui as utilisé mon appareil photo
c'est un film de genre un thriller
fantastique il ya des meurtres à paris
et on a un photographe qui est allemand
qui va commencer à être persécutés à
sentir persécuté par une présence
mystérieuse comme ça les ans qui va se
manifester à travers son appareil photo
et qui n'auront qui n'arriva pas à
saisir à prendre en photo et suspense
autour de ça on apprend plus sur le
personnage à travers cette maison comme
c'est ma première fois à cannes
c'est plus du bonus en fait ce que
j'attends c'est de prendre déjà observé
voir comment comment les gens
interagissent entre eux dans ce milieu
rencontrer des gens qui peuvent être
ensuite des tremplins des aspirations
les soutiens
et puis éventuellement en bonus
peut-être trouvé un acheteur pour pour
le film est diffusé en tout cas
quand l'espace soit aidé soit en vod par
le festival de cannes c'est aussi
l'occasion pour les professionnels du
réalisateur à l'exploitant de se pencher
sur la santé du cinéma qu'elle pineau et
le directeur du grenier à sel de trappes
le site accueille quelques 25000
spectateurs chaque année à cannes gaël
est à la recherche d'idées pour
développer l'activité de la salle et
attirer le grand public
dans notre métier on n'a pas vraiment de
formation et c'est pas évident
toujours se renouveler de développer de
nouvelles choses de donc là on vient ici
on prend des idées des uns des autres on
se rend compte en mange ensemble on sait
une chose assez informelle quand on fait
la queue pour attendre un film on en
profite aussi beaucoup pour pour
discuter écouter ce qu'on voit ce que
font les uns les autres et qu'il ya sur
ces pour voir les films parce que la
plupart des filles qui sont festival de
cannes on les retrouve dans nos salles
art et essai l'intérêt c'est pas 2 c'est
pas de rester un cinéma de mamie qui qui
attend les films toutes les semaines et
qui fait rien de particulier
on est toujours
on a toujours envie de dire quelque
chose je parlais de développement de
nouvelles idées de faire des choses à
côté du à côté du cinéma de faire des
partenariats de voir
vous avez fait un débat avec tel film
vous avez fait comment vous aviez ya
rien monsieur qui était avec une guitare
à d'accord c'est décidé qu'on peut avoir
comme ça et qu'on ait des changements
partagé qui permettent de ne pas avoir
toujours toujours toujours la même chose
en eau salée pas avoir uniquement un
film
une manière basique et on se quitte avec
notre star du jour son nom ne vous dit
peut-être rien et pourtant sylvain
chomet est un dessinateur scénariste de
bande dessinée de films d'animation il
est né à maisons laffitte
il a réalisé le film d'animation les
triplettes de belleville et notamment le
clip carmen de stromae à cannes il signa
un court métrage pour les talents adami
le titre c'est merci monsieur et madame
j'avais vu des triplettes de belleville
donc
oui après après j'ai regardé le parcours
bien sûr quand on travaille avec
quelqu'un c'est bien de savoir un peu de
connaître un peu l'univers il est très
bienveillant et en même temps il est
assez minutieux
c'est à dire que s'il ya quelque chose
qui ne va pas il va le dire avec toute
la douceur du monde
mais tant que ça n'ira pas appuyé
lâchera pas ce qui fait que
on sait qui nous amène à un endroit à
l'endroit où on sera le mieux et simone
et si on a du mal à y parvenir c'est pas
grave il prendra le temps qu'il faut hop
pour être pour qu'on soit au bon endroit
et ça c'est agréable sur certains
tournages quelquefois n'y a pas le temps
donc même si nous on sait qu'on n'a pas
été vraiment au bon endroit
y a pas le temps donc on continue et ça
c'est un peu frustrant
là vraiment tout était à sa place il
avait du temps pour nous il a été très
bienveillant l'équipe ça s'est très très
bien passé à les moteurs 1 - 1 sur 1 1re
la tienne 78 c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
et n'oubliez pas comme le dit claude
lelouch le cinéma est fait pour tous
ceux dont la curiosité est le plus grand
défaut
nous quittons cannes pour revenir à
saint quentin en yvelines l'essentiel de
la semaine que faut-il retenir de
l'actualité depuis elle lundi moi
j'étais encore plus sidéré qu'on puisse
tenir à mon égard ce type de propos le
soir même des révélations de la ferme au
pain avec des élus qui en plus font
référence directement à cette affaire
pour recommencer sur des blagues
machistes sexistes et et graveleuse j'ai
pas donné les noms parce qu'il ya eu un
emballement médiatique assez importants
comme vous avez pu le voir
et moi mon but c'est pas de clouer au
pilori en place publique et ça n'arrête
pas de la charge ni sa personne michel
auger est au courant c'est le seul avec
son chef de cabinet qui savent qu'ils
sont les deux personnes qui ont tenu ces
propos
je sais qu'il va les voir et je sais
qu'il va leur en parler
après dix semaines de travaux la place
des douves à voisins le bretonneux
affiche désormais un nouveau visage
un nouveau revêtement pour un espace
plus aéré que lévis chinois ont inauguré
samedi
ce matin à nancy le bretonneux la
nouvelle résidence du vélodrome pour
jeunes travailleurs a été inauguré le
montant de la réalisation de l'opération
réalisée par le bailleur osica s'élève à
12 millions huit cent quarante mille
euros avec la participation de l'état du
conseil régional et départemental mais
aussi de la caf
un bâtiment à l'architecturé
contemporaine comme vous pouvez le voir
sur les images qui comprend dix
logements accessibles aux personnes à
mobilité réduite
c'est une première dans les yvelines à
versailles une auto école sociale a vu
le jour en décembre dernier un
dispositif d'insertion partenariale
porté par le conseil départemental est
soutenu par une aide de 200 mille euros
du fonds social européen
cette auto école sociale comme son nom
l'indiqué tire son importance je lui
fait que l'accès à l'emploi est
totalement empêché par l'absence de
permis
surtout quand on est en grande couronne
de la région parisienne parce que
l'offre de transport en commun est
insuffisant
pour la créatrice c'est comme un retour
aux sources originaire de versailles où
elle a grandi jusqu'à ses 17 ans agnès b
a ouvert le 10 mai dernier la première
enseigne de sa marque dans la ville du
roi soleil
quarante ans après l'ouverture de son
premier point de vente à paris tu es
voulu rester un peu versaillaise
justement à l'ordre lancés dans des tons
c'est gris clair que j'adore les volets
gris clair comme ça
la maison et jaune pâle alors on est
resté avec des stores jaune pâle on a
voulu coller au contraire à
l'architecturé au lieu de plain pied un
truc qui aurait été différent
nous commençons ce journal avec et la
mobilisation des syndicats de police qui
a eu lieu aujourd'hui à paris les forces
de police ont manifesté aujourd'hui
place de la république objectif dénoncer
la haine anti policiers en france depuis
l'ouverture du débat sur la loi travail
selon les syndicats de police 350 agents
ont été blessés en deux mois dans
l'hexagone
la mobilisation a réuni aujourd'hui près
de 2000 personnes dont une centaine
venus des yvelines est déjà un très haut
niveau de mobilisation avec une séquence
fort puisque une grande partie de
l'établissement et armés ont mené
aujourd'hui vous verrez pas grand chose
les régressions sociales ne ferait pas
s'arrête jamais au port peu du privé 1
elle s'applique toulon cette borne et
véhicules à deux pas de la mairie tout
près de la gare versailles rive gauche
depuis la fin du mois d'avril la commune
possède 21 véhicules répartis sur trois
stations ça fonctionne très bien parce
que le démarrage en quinze jours trois
semaines on a déjà plus de 160 abonnés
annuels à bois d'arcy l'installation est
encore au stade de projet de station
devrait voir le jour à la zone
d'activités de la croix bonnet et près
de l'avenue paul vaillant couturier
grandes artères de la commune
c'est un vrai complément de transport
pour les artisiens mais aussi
du point de vue développement durable
puisque les stations seront équipées de
bornes de rechargement la famille
touahri s'agrandit le parc zoologique
yvelinois qui recense plus de 800
animaux et 120 espèces enregistré 37
naissances en 2016 dont une dizaine
depuis le début du mois de mai et après
ce résumé de la semaine 1 mois à présent
des sujets que nous développons dans
notre journal à partir de lundi nous
reviendrons sur la nuit des musées
samedi 21 mai 3000 établissements en
europe participent à cette 12e édition à
saint quentin en yvelines le musée de la
ville vous invite à découvrir sa
nouvelle exposition dans ses nouveaux
locaux en cours d'aménagement c'est au
sein de la médiathèque du canal à
montigny le programme également dans nos
éditions de la semaine prochaine de
l'opération parole de jardiniers qui
débute le 28 mai yvelines tourisme met
en avant cette année des rencontres avec
des jardiniers globe trotter certains
originaires du bout du monde d'autres
férus de méthodes ancestrales peu connu
et puis tout au long de la semaine dans
notre journal quotidien un dossier
consacré au cnc le centre national du
cinéma nous a ouvert ses locaux à bois
d'arcy où se trouvent les richesses du
patrimoine français du 7e art vous
verrez notamment comment se passe le
travail de restauration
un rendez vous à vous donner avant de
refermer cette édition dimanche à 18
heures nicolas kirillovitch ce recevra
sur l'antenne de radio sensations jean
michel fourgous le maire d'elancourt
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines
il sera question de la loi travail de la
présidentielle des législatives dès 2017
il réagira aussi aux propos tenus à
l'encontre d'une élue de la majorité des
propos sexistes il en était question
dans l'essentiel de l'actualité un peu
plus tôt dans ce journal
dans un instant vos idées sorties et
loisirs avec le 7-8 week-end de préparer
proposé par la rédaction est présenté
par mais quel ennemi d'euros rendez vous
lundi 18h en direct pour le journal 19
heures pour la première rediffusion
d'ici là n'oubliez pas de me suivre sur
les réseaux sociaux très bon week end
je